et si empruntait devenait plus cher
depuis peu et taux d'intérêt remontent
sur les marchés ce qui laisse craindre
un renchérissement du crédit elle partie
des états unis le phénomène commence à
gagner l'europe alors va-t-on vers une
fin de ce qu'on appelle l'argent gratuit
ou presque dans quelle mesure cette
retombée des taux est elle un danger
pour les entreprises et les ménages les
plus endettés c'est l'objet de l'édito
échos ce soir bonsoir jacques sapir
bonsoir c'est fanny rey jacques cette
hausse dont des taux d'intérêt est elle
une véritable menace
alors oui c'est potentiellement une
menace parce que va voir que les taux
d'endettement que ce soit les taux
d'endettement des ménages ou des
entreprises sont très élevés et
effectivement ça serait une catastrophe
si les taux remonter brutalement
maintenant il faut dire que ce n'est pas
encore le cas sauf aux états unis où on
assiste depuis cet été à une remontée
constante des taux on voit que pour
l'instant cette remontée des taux est
très modérée néanmoins il y a clairement
un problème sous jacent là qui est
présent alors dans quelle mesure jacques
l'endettement est il un problème pour
les ménages mais aussi pour les
entreprises évidemment alors pour les
ménages si vous voulez c'est un problème
tout à fait évident les ménages
américains les ménages britanniques y
sont parmi les plus endettés aurait
beaucoup de mal à supporter une forte
remontée des taux mais même le cas des
ménages français regardez les ménages
français ont vu leur taux d'endettement
augmenté de 60 à 65% en l'équivalent de
quatre trimestres
donc oui ça peut être potentiellement un
énorme problème
et puis il n'ya pas que les ménages il
ya aussi toute la question de
l'endettement des entreprises est là
pour la france c'est un problème
vraiment très important parce que en ce
qui concerne l'endettement des
entreprises
on voit que la france elle se situe
pratiquement au niveau du japon
ou au niveau de l'espagne donc des pays
qui sont où les entreprises sont très
endettés et là aussi si les taux
augmentent et ça pourrait être une
catastrophe pour l'économie française et
pour les états jacques ne sont ils pas
eux aussi très endetté oui naturellement
naturellement les états se sont tous
très endettés alors sans même parler du
cas du japon qui est endetté à
l'équivalent de 250 % de son pib
on a aussi le problème des états qui
sont à plus de 100 % de dette par
rapport à leur pib
maintenant il faut dire une chose c'est
que si les états ont pu justement
s'endetter de telle manière
c'est bien parce que l'argent a été
quasiment gratuit c'est le même problème
d'ailleurs pour par exemple les
entreprises ou pour les ménages outre la
question du revenu des ménages
donc on voit bien ici que c'est en
raison de ces taux très faibles que les
états ont pratiquement tous décidé de
laisser filer la dette et jeanne
justement quelle est l'ampleur de cette
de cette hausse des taux dont on parle
alors pour ce qui est des états unis
on voit que c'est un plan avait quand
même pas négligeable puisqu'on est
revenue pratiquement au niveau où on
était avant la crise sanitaire et gagne
un point qui était tout à fait
intéressant c'est que sur cette courbe
alors c'est peut-être pas très visible à
l'écran mais en fait les taux remontent
ce taux à 10 ans remonte depuis la fin
du mois de juillet 2020 donc là où il y
a un problème et comme je vous le disais
les to sont maintenant pratiquement au
niveau où il était au début de 2020 donc
on a bien le sentiment là que l'économie
américaine
en tous les cas pour ce qui concerne sa
sphère financière eh bien elles semblent
être revenus à la situation d'avant la
crise financière et est ce donc jacques
la même chose dans la zone euro oui là
aussi on voit que les taux sont en train
de remonter mais non il remonte d'abord
beaucoup moins les les tours de la zone
euro
sont encore majoritairement négatifs ce
n'est pas le cas aux états unis
il remonte depuis seulement le mois de
décembre dernier
pas depuis le mois de juillet donc on
voit que c'est un phénomène qui est
nettement moins important mais néanmoins
il est très impressionnant de voir que
tous les taux remonte
qu'il s'agisse du taux à 10 ans du taux
à 5 ans du taux à un an donc tous les
tourments et alors quand on parle des
taux européens
on parle aussi évidemment dépôts
français voilà il s'affiche et alors
pour ce qui est de la france mais il ya
peut-être une petite différence avec la
moyenne des taux européens en france
bien sûr on voit sur les courbes le
point d'inflexion et on voit que la
courbe des taux à 10 ans commence à
remonter mais ça reste encore beaucoup
plus faible que dans la moyenne en
europe
évidemment beaucoup plus faible qu'aux
états unis et donc de ce point de vue là
on peut penser que nous sommes
relativement protégé alors jacques est
ce à dire qu'on est tranquille
finalement pour le moment en france
alors à court terme
oui c'est tout à fait c'est tout à fait
évident et il faut comprendre une chose
c'est que une hausse des taux serait
tellement catastrophiques pour
l'économie que ce soit pour l'état pour
les entreprises voire pour les ménages
que la banque centrale européenne fera
tout pour maintenir des taux très
faibles
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui il y avait une
réunion à la banque centrale européenne
et la banque centrale européenne a
décidé d'augmenter au contraire ses
rachats d'obligations aux banques ce qui
est une méthode en réalité pour re faire
baisser les taux mais mais il faut bien
voir que en dépit de ce genre de
politique malgré tout il y à un
mouvement de pression à la hausse des
taux ce qui fait que s'il n'y a pas de
risque dans l'immédiat
on ne peut pas exclure des problèmes à
plus long terme un an un an et demi
alors je vous repose donc la question
faut-il quand même s'inquiéter de ce
mouvement de hausse des taux pour les
mois et les années qui viennent
vous avez tout à fait raison de poser le
problème dans ces termes
s'il n'y a pas de problème dans
l'immédiat ou
bien entendu une hausse des taux
pourrait être catastrophique dans l'état
actuel de nos économies après il faut
voir un autre problème c'est que on est
en présence d'un mouvement qui existe à
la fois aux états unis mais aussi en
europe
on l'a vu simplement ce qui est
différent aujourd'hui c'est que les
états unis ont pris de l'avancé et
pourquoi ont-ils pris de l'avancé
et bien parce que l'économie américaine
se redresse beaucoup plus rapidement que
l'économie de la zone euro ou que
l'économie de l'union européenne
d'une certaine manière et ça sera ma
troisième observation et bien le retard
que nous avons pris dans ce mouvement de
hausse des taux et bien ce retard il
traduit aussi un retard économique que
nous sommes en train de prendre par
rapport aux états unis et donc il n'est
pas non plus une si bonne nouvelle que
cela
maintenant il faut dire que les banques
centrales on peut le penser vont
toujours veillé au grain mais jacques on
surveillera sait-on comme le lait sur le
feu merci à vous et à la semaine
prochaine